dans the voice on imagine que les
battles ne se joue entre les candidats
est ce qu'on ne sait pas c'est que la
guerre est aussi très actif du côté des
coachs car si cette année avec la crise
sanitaire la production du programme a
décidé de baisser de façon conséquente
les cachets de certains jurés il
semblerait que la répartition des
budgets ne conviennent pas à tout le
monde
d'après le magazine public florent pagny
aurait complètement revu son salaire à
la baisse passant de 900000 euros par
saison à 550 milles s'est jamais non
plus très très grave
donc ça reste sympa un salaire tout de
même au-dessus de celui de marc lavoine
qui s'élève à 400 mille euros je trouve
ça super forme mais le fond du problème
viendrait de la part de deux autres
coachs amel bent a été augmenté son
salaire se voit quasiment doublé à l'est
on peut souffler deux buts ça y est
c'est fait alors que le petit nouveau de
l'aventuré vianney fait une entrée
fracassante avec un salaire mirobolant
c'est incroyable alors êtes vous choqué
par les salaires révélé des jurés de the
voice
alors j'ai audiard est ce que déjà c'est
un poison bret parce que moi je voudrais
dire il que des potes dans le jury dont
amel bent et vianney qui est vraiment un
pote
voilà très proche de moi vianney et je
le dis voilà vianney si je n'ai jamais
demandé parce que c'est un pote on va
pas parler de ça mais voilà en tout cas
ce que je peux dire c'est que c'est pas
leur faute si on leur propose ça
rigolait voilà partage je le dis parce
que vianney c'est un super pote et je
peux vous dire que vianney il pense pas
du tout à nos années c'est un artiste
mais vraiment de ouf je le connais bien
j'ai passé vraiment des moments avec lui
j'ai joué au pad hall avec lui j'ai fait
plein de trucs avec lui je le dis bien
né c'est un artiste même quand tout ce
qu'il fait c'est un artiste il pense pas
à l'argent alors vous
non je veux c'est vrai que c'est des
négociations qui passe par des agents
donc c'est des vrais chiffres ça peut
paraître choquant mais c'est les agents
qui négocient beaucoup d'argent et ils
ont bien raison il faut savoir qu'en
france on est des petits joueurs jouent
les sorties des salaires des coachs de
the voice aux états unis c'est que dix
fois plus que ça à regarder non pharrell
williams 8 millions shakira denis val de
marne 16 ans une crise on arrête un
mytho et bien sûr que si c'est des stars
internationales
on a fait un tonneau mais il faut dire
qu'aux états unis
voilà c'est ça les artistes réinvesti
dieu
c'est très prestigieux et en france font
qu'on est en train de brader le jury
donc c'est vraiment pas mal alors le
jury est fort on le jurerait plus en
plus fort dans ce match et moi j'attends
je veux et c'est cammalleri et l'âge est
là pour la première fois le fantasme de
la production c'est d'avoir un rappeur
dans un bus
ils ont demandé à m higgins et la
refuser voilà pour la première fois
alors il y aura le rappeur howald qui
sera la porte lavoine qui fera partie du
deck la toile voilà donc c'est gilles
verdez est choqué je suis choqué les
gens diraient pourquoi j'ai mis des
lunettes dans un instant aussi oui pour
cette gens qui réagissent
ce sont des salaires qui sont en baisse
par rapport aux éditions précédentes
mais qui sont astronomiques notamment
dans la période actuelle les gens
étaient joueurs de foot là ouais
la jeune fan de foot alors un bon joueur
de foot je mets un choc et pourquoi n'at
elle pas de choquer pour les jours je
suis moins choqué par ce que il
les joueurs de foot draine d'abord des
recettes fiscales est tellement
importante et on veut là aussi mis à
l'ordre du jour il m'appelle pas
agréable quoi qu'ils payent pas d'impôts
bien ici ils payent des impôts mais
attendez je vois c'est une émission on
ferme mais pas du tout cela c'est
l'émission faire édition voilà c'était
pour la ces dernières séances et samarie
toujours ça marche toujours
c'est beaucoup moins bien qu'avant mais
ça marche toujours il disproportionné
par rapport à 0
c'est alors je ne critique pas vianney
via mais il est venu comme sauveur de
l'émission effectivement c'est et où je
pense qu'il va sur les versions mois et
donc il
ils ont dit à vianney tu seras le plus
payé bah oui de tous les petits nouveaux
de l'histoire mais je vous dis bien mais
je pense qu'il va sauver l'émission mais
vous dire il est quand même 20 prime
donc fond on va ramener ça avec moi et
moi faire la division de là que viennent
et il a dix sept mille euros par
émission excusez moi sur tf1 c'est pas
un salaire énorme pour un parent c'est
énorme si la maison mais aujourd'hui
j'ai pas dis que c'est en cacahuète
tombées nez là je peux sur l'arrêté
je pense que c'est moi ça m'agace mardi
vous explique pas ce que vous avez votre
famille elle gagné mais je vous dis pas
envie de parler de ces martyrs il par
rapport à tf1 évidemment c'est une somme
colossale
c'est évidemment mais par rapport à la
chaîne et par rapport à un prize à
l'animateur a plus que dix sept mille
euros et celle je vous dire qu'on
prenait briscoe c'est vrai c'est vrai ce
pathétique ou par mois donc je lui dis
qu effectivement sur un ben s'assure 20
prime c'est une somme énorme mais c'est
en dessous en dessous du salaire moyen
car mais jamais je suis d'accord
juriez bon alors je vous le dis là le
seul moyen d'un animateur s'est trompé
en facturant facture mais c'est pareil
c'est la peinture la voilà donc fait
rappeler laurent facture ça fait quoi à
peu près 20 milles
non non on est dans un voilà le celui
qui est payé un peu plus on va dire que
c'est chez panisse à 550 milles ça fait
voilà ça fait sur survint prime ça fait
vingt-cinq mille euros hors taxes par
prime c'est pas non voilà c'est dans la
moyenne normale de la chaîne nicolas
ferrier voudrait le jury de toute façon
c'est sur ce format est ultra pas bien
sûr mais pas du tout vous dire il tombe
vous dites pour noah pour moi rées p
pour moi je vous dire le jury est aussi
important que les chroniques cherche pas
à mon poste à la bce pour moi que pour
moi le shérif doit être plus payer que
l'animateur a un je vous le jure
voilà c'est ce qu'on se disait on
vraiment abrutis qui forme des gens qui
font des carrières su plaire à raymond
brodeur
on a mal on est des cons à madame
premier des non mais c'est que ya eu des
tests avec julien clerc ou avec d'autres
qui n'ont pas marché qui n'ont pas
frustré oui oui je rappelle qui est
aussi le retour de florent pagny qui
comme quelqu'un de très sympathique
yedaya dominé oui mais non mais c'est
pas ça c'est si je veux dire c'est une
vraie valeur alors pour l'émission donc
à un moment donné il faut être juste
aussi c'est à dire c'est l'offre et la
demande bien s'il voulait mettre dans
les jurys mais chaque membre ils se
prennent la tête toute l'année quand ils
veulent quand ils doivent remplacer une
paire axiale c'est parce que tout le
monde ne peut plus riches sont moins
bien payés que nikos ou mieux payé dit
la vérité avait pas je connais pas le
cas ici avec moi je sais alors a alors
dit qu'ils seraient les dernières en
tout cas est touché 27000 euros par
émission avril au dessus donc il nous
tue au moins jusqu'à n'avait rarement
d'accord je peux écouter alors qu'on
sait qu'on doit je sais compter à moi tu
dis ça ah oui 20 x 20 40 les 400 mm x
540 540 millions merci marc ici la bonne
soupe il a fait une série vdev dit la
sonde a bien compris que c'était un
monde à part la télé c'est pas la vraie
vie donc c'est sûr que si vous posez la
question à quelqu'un de lambda il à vous
dire oui bien sûr le sait trop si on
prend en compte le milieu dans le milieu
on peut se dire que c'est pas trop été
donné que c'est des choses qui
correspondent à d'autres salles est ce
que ça vous choque
non ici tiffany ça la chope et oui ça me
choque je suis d'accord avec tout ce qui
a amené ici
le jury est exceptionnel vient neige
l'adorent en a même parlé ensemble de
l'est
quand il est venu sur une radio il avait
dit que ça s'était dit que c'est une
diva mais s'il vous plaît vous êtes fous
toi diane est une diva c'est plus et ben
c'est vrai que c'est le plus simple du
monde c'est ce qui a écrit ce relais
s'enfouir on s'en fout donc c'est pour
vous dire que c'est n'importe quoi c'est
pas du tout une diva et non ce que je
veux dire c'est que on s'en fout des
infos donner votre avis c'est ce que je
suis en train de dire alors oui et que
c'est totalement indécent pourquoi parce
que déjà en plus ils disent ils ont revu
à la baisse c'est une somme conséquente
quand même cinq cent cinquante mille
euros et pour reprendre le les joueurs
de foot
ils sont assis juste sur un fauteuil et
ils doivent tout donner et laisser
l'affairé opel et déjà pas bien ce
serait vraiment aller au bout de sa vie
si il fait régner vous ai rêvé ou à 4
heures du matin depuis trois heures avec
vincent cerrutti il faut tout de suite
ou livrons des entraînements ils sont
pendant 90 minutes sur un terrain de
foot
tout ça pendant trois ans j'ai perdu la
terre la pétition non mais elle a perdu
la tête
alors qu'est ce qu'ils font j'aimerais
j'aimerais quelqu'un d'intelligent ne va
pas vous dit vous savez gérer les sites
et géraldine cgra nerfs d'abord ils ont
pas être oubliés bien embarrassant
violent oui mais il m'est fait un
flingue sur la tombe de terre bien sûr
encore fait la wii jemal érigeant jamais
ça c'est la première chose
ensuite moi je trouve que d'abord gym
qui défont toujours le droit des femmes
à je trouve que c'est génial comme amel
bent à 1 et un salaire qui augmente et
bien sûr bien fait pour ta que c'est
très très bien pas ça veut dire que
quelque part la bêtise se battre dans la
même catégorie que les hommes ensuite
bienvenus il est auteur interprète
baronnies composite blanche et annonce à
dire que c'est énorme pour lui en plus
il a composé pour kenji qu'est john
wayne donc plein de moyens non doxa de
vol et donc ses fans pour le chocolat
pur fait ça donc c'est formidable pour
le programme et pour moi il n'y a aucun
problème c'est juste à chaque fois le
turc et le côté un peu démago ils sont
trop payés mon dieu c'est horrible mais
pas du tout près ça va pas oui sinon
rien d'indécent à marseille achille
à partir du moment où ça s'inscrit dans
une réalité économique cercle the voice
est rentable pour tf1 c'est rentable
pour la boîte de prod qui produit
l'émission donc qu'ils soient payés 300
mille cinq cent mille 1
2 millions appartement il ya un système
économique comme pour les journaux et
qui génère de l'argent n'y a rien de
choquant si ça génère gagnent de
l'argent sur leur dos c'est normal que
ça génère et surtout il voyait surtout
ils font pleurer alors là c'est le
coville et surtout ils font plus rien
pendant cette série moment là parce que
florent pagny n'a pas pu tourner chaque
fois qu'il va sur deux voies qui peut
pas tourner investissons ça mais
attendez il faut être juste aussi par
rapport au téléscripteur su parce que là
on est en train d'afficher des trucs qui
effectivement peut être choquant sauf
que les gens ils bottent ce sont des
gens qui a + b king coach il reste des
mois et des mois à travailler sur le
programme choses il ya plein de choses
qu'on le voit pas mais c'est un
investissement quand même pour un
accident dit ouah alors les chéris
ayotte nouvelle qui est arrivé et je
vous le dis ça me fait pas plaisir parce
que aussi au sirop contacté et on s'est
parlé avec karine ferri et que j'aime
beaucoup voilà on puisse qu'on
s'entendait très bien car il est un
malentendu je pense que voilà les voilà
c'est en plus avec les relations avec
tf1 ont fait qu'elle est mais c'était un
peu dégradée entre nous deux mais qu'il
est j'aime beaucoup et il ya une info
qui dirait que karine elle serait écarté
de the voice qu'elle coanimait pourtant
depuis 2013 et j'étais pas ça parce que
votre nom ses réponses et aux caisses ne
rien karine ferri je pense qu'ils se
trompent parce que dans les sondages
elle ressort toujours très très bien et
les téléskis et dans les sondages de
l'animateur elles ressortent toujours
dans les préférées mais après je vous
dis j'ai souvent par était copain avec
quelle karine ferri tout ça mais je sais
juste
en tout cas c'est vrai que dans les
sondages d'animateurs karine ferri sort
toujours très très bien les
téléspectateurs les menaces que c'est
pas une erreur ne s'en passer et karine
ferri avec imma pour moi même sans quoi
c'est pas les préférées qui marche le
plus vous n'y êtes jamais et vous
marchez très bien oui mais bon c'est pas
pareil celle de combat j'ai une gueule
de con ce papa elle fait partie des
grands oubliés tf1 sarko show qu'elle
est très bonne à l'antenne elle est très
sympathique je pense qu'il est
extrêmement populaire elle est jolie et
elle me donne que des légères mais l'a
sifflé femme là qui fait exactement le
téléphone lui donne que des co animation
je pense qu'elle mérite beaucoup plus et
qu'elle devrait aller sur une autre
chaîne sont les hôpitaux lui non mais
non mais ils étaient là qui peut pas pu
choquer honnête son fils
verdi depuis des années elle est presque
milliers par tf1 qui la met de côté car
il à bassoues qui ne lui donne plus rien
faux profils guirec verismic narc ont
fermé ou il a bafoué la manière dont on
a étalé évincé depuis des années est
totalement injuste de la part de la
chaîne et leur choix mais est ce que n'a
pas mené moi mais moi c'est là que moi
qui vais peut-être la plus dure parce
que moi je ne me souvenais plus qu'elle
était dans le programme
ah ouais nettement mais nous il ya
planté un petit show non là car elle
fait l'année dernière les plus belles
marié puel a fait danse avec les stars
c'est par ici en mission là rien